We've had written history for 5000 years.
People have been generally literate for less
than 500 years.
But we’ve had culture for 150,000 years.
Identifiable culture for at least 25,000 so
the vast period of our enculturation was preliterate
enculturation before we could write down the
rules and transmit them.
How were they transmitted assuming we had
culture well there's a variety of mechanisms.
we have a tendency to see elements of the
world in personified form because most of
the inter relationships we have with the world
are actually social or interpersonal relationships
so that’s basically how our brain is structured
and as we evolved we developed the capacity
to extend our cognitive ability beyond the
merely social to take in the world as such
but the categories that we use to do that
was still fundamentally social.
Now the reason the unknown per se is symbolized
as feminine is because the critical feature
of the feminine and I don’t mean the female
individual I mean the feminine category is
its capacity to generate new forms.
And the unknown is such is is logically and
appropriately symbolized by the feminine because
it’s the bringer forth of all things which
is to say that the background of existence
the unknowable background of existence is
the thing that generates everything.
paired with that of course according to the
schema that we've been working with is the
archetype of the great father.
and the archetype of the great father is the
archetype of tradition fundamentally.
The great weight of the past
because as you incorporate your past the past
of your culture through the intermediation
of your parents you learn routines and rituals
for structure in the unknown now those routines
and rituals are patterns of action that you
use in the world as such.
And also a complex patterns of action that
you use to structure your own interpretations
and your own motor output and your own conceptualizations
when you're dealing with other people and
so that would be the absorption the most fundamentally
of your cultural rules and the fact of those
cultural rules and their incarnation in you
essentially keeps chaos at bay which means
if two of you share the same cultural structure,
assuming you're playing the same game so to
speak that means that you can each predict
each other’s responses which is very, very
useful because that way you can be sure that
you can trust the other person you can more
or less infer their goals because after all
their value structure’s similar to yours
and if you can infer their goals that means
you can embody their emotions,
So that’s the benevolent aspect of tradition
right the part that protects and shelters
you and structures the nature of your being
in the face of existential terror and doubt
so to speak but there's also an aspect of
tradition that’s terrible, tyrannical.
it’s the part that marches young men off
to war say in defense of the structures that
it’s protecting.
It’s the part that says when you're a teenager
wear this and not this or you'll be the target
of mockery for all your peers.
It’s the part of the structure that crushes
the creative life out of you because the tyrannical
aspect of social order doesn’t want your
creative life so to speak what it wants is
your obedience because your obedience is what
makes the machine run smooth and so you're
always in an ambivalent relationship with
regards to security to authority on the one
hand it provides you shelter and what you
need and allows you to gain the benefits of
literally thousands and thousands of years
of cultural evolution.
On the other hand it’s the thing that makes
you obey or face the painful consequences
thereof which can range from mere social exclusion
and consequent reexposure to the unknown to
truly oppressive practices designed to make
you be exactly like everyone else or else.
And so you could say most particularly again
that that’s a standard existential problem
it’s a problem that’s faced by people
in every place and in ever culture, balancing
the appropriate attitude towards culture
So the most fundamental representation of
culture can be portrayed essentially in this
manner I think.
And what you see here is the dragon of chaos
of course lurking in the background and what
that means is that all forms come from the
formless and that the father itself is a primary
form a representation of God the father and
God the father in the Christian trinity is
the representation of the positive and the
security and the tyrannical aspect of social
order right God has a set of rules for you,
you bloody well better listen to those rules
if you don’t all hell’s gonna break loose
and you know that’s a pretty reasonable
summary of how things work unfortunately.
so on the one hand God offers security on
the other hand he offers tyranny and in total
that basically represents order so you can
see this representation is quite useful; shows
God’s standing over this city which of course
is a city committed to him fundamentally so
it operates under the moral principals that
he represents and behind him is a representation
of the sun which is partly a representation
of the source of all life partly a representation
of the source of consciousness and illumination
right because you're conscious during the
day and partly a halo representing a sort
of transcendent nature of the of the social
order that structures existence so it’s
a primary phenomenon and it’s only to say
that in all human experience there's a cultural
aspect and a natural aspect and a funny thing
is the cultural aspect in some ways is as
natural as the natural aspect right because
we’re social beings we can’t exist without
society, society’s structures as our very
nature.
And we’re beneficiaries and victims.
And so then just as the case - just as is
the case with the feminine there's a two aspects
that can be represented metaphorically with
regards to the masculine you can say well
the secure aspect of social order is the wise
king and you can see it written in medieval
representation of him here sitting on his
throne calmly in a relatively open posture
that means he’s ready to listen to supplicants
to people who are coming to talk to him.
He’s holding an orb with a cross on top
of it which means essentially that he’s
in control of the world and that the world
is subordinated to something else that’s
represented by the cross.
A wise and just ruler and then his mirror
image here is the son devouring king a very
common mythological theme the father who wants
to destroy his son and shades of the Oedipal
conflict in that of course if you remember
your Freud but basically what it means is
this is that despite the fact that every human
being is an offspring of culture by nature,
every human being is also in the terrible
position of facing the fact that their very
individuality is likely to be crushed out
of them during during the socialization process.
And in a sense that’s really not an that’s
really not avoidable I mean if you're subject
to really tyrannical socialization it’s
obviously a much more cardinal problem right
but even if you're subject to socialization
under normal circumstances you are still what
you are rather than the many fold things that
you could've otherwise been and just to give
you some sense of how dramatic a process this
really is one of the things you should know
is that you actually die into your brain so
one of the things you might wonder is why
is it that death evolved it doesn’t really
make up much sense from a Darwinian perspective,
right because you'd make the presupposition
that if you could just stick around and father
children say for 250 years you'd be doing
a lot better job than the poor sap who only
lived to be 30 so why is it that you only
live to be 70 and really your period of fertility
is over say by the time you're 40.
Why would that be what's the utility of death?
And then you remember well the environment’s
always changing right in this chaotic manner
that’s represented by the great mother.
Can you change with it and in answer to that
is yes but only to a certain point.
Which is why as people age they tend to become
more and more alienated from the current culture
right they’ve they’ve adopted their position
of being say which is a more or less fixed
by the time they're 25 or so once their pre
frontal cortex matures and then after that
the world gets away from them they don’t
have enough biological resources left to constantly
undergo new revolutionary neurological processes
and part of the reason is this.
You have more neuro connections in your brain
when you're first born than you do for the
rest of your life, any other time in your
life and as you learn when you're an infant
and as you learn say over the first two years
what happens is that there's a plentitude
of circuits and they die off leaving only
those circuits that have a function and you
think about that it’s kind of a quasi Darwinian
process.
And so what that means is that as you mature
and become fixed in your form you know to
adopt your personality whatever it becomes,
what's happening is that the excess possibility
in some sense is being demolished by experience.
So the tyrannical aspect of enculturation
is something that’s real because it makes
you in large part what you are.
And you have to understand as well that that’s
necessary because it’s better to be something,
in the final analysis it’s better to be
something than to be nothing.
But you know we still have residual dreams
like those expressed by Peter Pan say who's
the boy that never wants to grow up because
he doesn’t wanna attain any final and fixed
form and it’s interesting because in one
respect as you progress through your life
you're climbing assuming things are going
well you're climbing to ever new heights but
on the other hand the direction that you're
going in constantly narrows as you age so
there's a real trade off there and I think
the existential angst that’s caused as a
consequence of that trade off is often real.
And I also think that adolescents and early
adults feel this most intently which is part
of the reason why they tend to rebel against
social structures in general you know whether
it’s the military industrial complex or
the corporate world or globalization or what
have you is that you have these large structures
that represent the tyrannical aspect of social
being and it’s no wonder that the fact of
those structures engenders rebellion, it should.
On the other hand it’s also no wonder that
structures like that exist because if they
didn't exist then people would have no way
of interrelating their social being and we
would revert back to the sort of Hobbsian
state of war where everybody’s arms are
around everybody else’s throat.
That doesn’t mean the payoff is always good.
So… the Freudians of course had a real field
day with this, and we’re most fundamentally
concerned by it.
part of the reason that Freudian psychology
has had such an immense impact on western
and world culture is because Freud came along
just when classical Judeo-Christian mythological
structures were on the on a serious decline
in the west and Freud stepped in with a secularized
mythological version of reality which said
well there's nature and that’s the Id right
that’s the wild and untamed impulses that
spring up from the animal mind and there's
the ego which is the individual whose in many
ways a pawn of these id like forces and then
on top of the ego crushing it down into the
id so to speak is the superego which is the
internal and external embodiment of social
order and morality so you can see the mythological
substructure underlying Freud.
Freud said well ego is always being shaped
by the superego and always compulsion it’s
“don’t, don’t”.
It’s always “no” it’s like Old Testament
morality and the incarnation of the ten commandments.
Whatever you wanna do if it feels good the
probability is high that it’s immoral from
the perspective of the social world
and you can really see this with children
you know it’s really remarkable to watch
them because my sense is and I don’t think
this is just because I'm a particularly tyrannical
father is that children often get in more
trouble for having fun than they do for any
other reason because their capacity for unbridled
enjoyment is so unbridled that it actually
poses a threat to orderly structure so you
know if a child really gets in an active mood
and is playing a very active game I mean especially
if they're somewhere between say 3 and 5 they
can tear your house to shreds and no time
no time flat and you're always bawling them
out like no, no, no quiet down don’t do
that.
And you know they're smiling away and they're
happier than any adult you're ever gonna see
in your entire life and you’re doing everything
you can to push them down so that they're
they can sit quietly and read a book or whatever
it is you think they should be doing and that’s
really nasty and horrible but by the same
token it’s absolutely necessary because
if they don’t learn to bring their impulses
even their impulses their ludic impulses right
their impulses to play under control then
nobody else can stand them and if they don’t
get access to the resources there in the social
world man they have one dismal life laid out
in front of them so anyways so that’s an
early description of the genesis of the conflict
say between the ego and the superego and I
just wanted to point that out because it’s
not just sex and aggression that gets regulated
right we can understand why that might happen
but it’s also playfulness and creativity
and spontaneity and all the things that we
associated with the joy of being that the
terrible tyrannical social structure puts
a clamp on.
So Jaak Panksepp for example has recently
demonstrated that children, boys because it’s
usually boys who have attention deficit disorder
which is generally diagnosed in the school
room do much better if they're placed on methylphenidate
which is a kind of amphetamine fundamentally
but normal kids do better on amphetamines
too by the way they can focus better they
can focus more and they can pay attention
more mostly what methylphenidate does is suppress
play so Panksepp notes is that well what’s
happening with these ADHD kids hyperactive
kids is they're more playful more boisterously
playful which is tends to be a masculine attribute
in juvenile forms of many mammals they're
boisterously playful give them a little methylphenidate
that shuts down their play behaviour and they
can sit down and focus you know and well you
can understand how even if you might think
that’s necessary because apparently many
people do you can also still understand that
by the same token that probably represents
some kind of loss because we like to see kids
play and it’s good for them besides, so
anyways Freud says the ego pops up it’s
all thrilled to death with the world a superego
comes along and shuts it down and that’s
a fate that befalls all of us and not only
that because Freud’s a pretty wise man all
things considered he doesn’t say that’s
all to the bad he says that’s the price
we pay for social being and fair enough.
you see this happening in children all the
time where part of what they do as they mature
is to adopt roles so they’ll play being
a father or being a mother say and what they're
doing is pulling in what they see as a as
the world view that characterizes parenthood
embodying the father playing out the role
and trying to organize their motivational
structures within observed framework say that
the father provides and that’s an introjections
of social wisdom if you can imagine that the
role of father say has a structure like one
structure would be well if you’re a father
and you're around to model then you have to
be taking care of the children or at least
you have to be there often enough so that
you can be a target of modeling and so you
can imagine that the spirit of the father
that’s modeled at least in the optimal circumstances
is one that deals out rules and order but
that also provides nurturing care and support
and that’s a kind of story we know fathers
who aren't like that and maybe we know fathers
who are too much like that but all things
considered on the average you have a father
role and children attempt to interject that
and that’s part of the way that they learn
to modulate their own motivational resources
so for example if the child observes the father
and the mother sharing which means taking
each others motivational states into account
then they can act out the game of sharing
with a doll say representing a child and what
they're doing is trying to imagine what it’s
like inside that doll’s head treating it
like a person, by embodying the potential
motivations and emotions states of that pretend
object in their own body, and then by trying
to organize a high order structure which would
be like the tea party where tea is shared
a higher order structure where you have a
turn because you want a turn because you're
thirsty like me and then I have a turn and
we both get what we want and we can exchange
information
and well that’s a little bit more optimistic
representation of the tyranny of social order
that pure compulsion right because what it
suggests is there's a way that you can organize
the way you are genuinely and the way I am
genuinely so that we both are genuine yet
we get something more than we would get if
we would just fire ourselves and so you think
that with kids they like to play by themselves
but by the time they're about 3 and a half
or four boy they have a hunger for other children
and they’ll do anything in order to go out
and play with other kids so you can say that
well if you take all the toys off your bed
I’ll go let you play with your friend and
like the toys are off there in two tenths
of a second and they're out the door because
they have this primary need to go out and
experiment with the social world and in large
way in large part that’s how they build
the complex higher order more abstract structures
that enable them to regulate their motive
their motivational states and their emotional
state without just “no”.
It’s a more sophisticated way of doing it
right it’s better to play a game with someone
than to engage in a battle of wills with them.
Because then there's no compulsion there's
just mutual participation and that’s critical
because one of the things that the notion
of the tyranny of the social order brings
up as a question is all right all right so
you have to take part in society.
You have to take your part in the social world,
yet the social world wants its pound of flesh
or its 60 pounds of flesh depending on where
you live.
On the one so you're damned if you do so to
speak and you're damned if you don’t what
do you do as a consequence of facing that
challenge and so you remember with the great
mother with chaos and the unknown the way
you meet the challenge is to understand that
the things you don’t understand are dangerous
and frightening and that if you encounter
them they can hurt you and that this is real
but you don’t run away all the same if you're
trying to get somewhere the things you don’t
understand happen you can’t shut yourself
down you have to explore cautiously and try
to gain new knowledge.
Well how do you organize your social being
well let’s make the presupposition that
you got half a dozen or so fundamental motivational
states right so what they are is your subjugation
to a world of apriory deities.
You see in children rage fear, hunger anger
affiliation, love, the capacity of play all
value sets.
Which have their own goal like behavioral
patterns their own world view their own way
of manifesting themselves all those are innate
they're all dependent on pre wired neural
architectural systems.
They have to unfold in experience but they're
there.
Okay and so let’s say that’s what you
come into the world with and that’s what
you come into the world with but then the
fact that you're in the world poses a more
complex problem which is well yeah you’ve
got one motivational state happening you're
angry.
But then you’ve got another you have to
worry about which is you'd like to be affiliated
with someone.
Like your sibling so you got a real conflict
with your sibling it’s like you really hate
them but you really like them too and you
wanna play with them so what do you do about
that?
Well you'd say a behaviourally disregulated
child who isn't well socialized they're impulsive.
They don’t they don’t act as if they take
the future into account so they heavy future
discount their impulses what does that mean.
if you watch a child have a temper tantrum
which around two they're really prone to it’s
like it’s a phenomena it’s like a tornado
on a real small scale.
Child’s just flipped out if you saw an adult
do that you'd run away screaming right.
And, they're completely dominated by this
emotional state.
And my sense watching that has always been
to try to help the kid not have that happen
to them because it looks like a terrible catastrophe
for their emerging ego right I mean they're
trying to get their world together and something
frustrates them and (WHOOMP!) up come these
amygdalic projections that govern the anger
hypothalamic even more primitive and just
like blow them over and then they're on the
floor and they're holding their breath and
they're turning blue and they're having a
fit and then it takes them like 15 minutes
to recover.
So they have to take themselves into account
as total as complete beings and that’s the
emergence of a higher order morality but it’s
more complicated than that because not only
do they have the problem of themselves which
is a bad enough problem but then they have
the problem of the other person.
So what’s the proper response of the individual,
given that he or she is threatened by the
natural world and the unknown on the left
hand, and threatened by the social order and
its tyranny on the right hand, but also dependent
on the natural world and chaos for all good
things and all new information, and dependent
on the social order for their very mode of
being, right, caught between four paradoxes
all at the same time.
How can that route be properly negotiated?
Well, and then you can look at hero mythology,
and the most common plot, and I would say
in some ways the only plot, although there
are variations of this that are endless, romantic
variations or adventure story variations,
or variations of failed heroic endeavor.
Still the only plot goes something like this:
there’s a current state of being, now that
can be represented by a psychological state,
your current personality, it can be represented
by your family, it can be represented by your
extended social group, your city, your town,
your country, your ecosystem, your, your,
your, in science fiction frequently the entire
global community, right, a structure is threatened;
by what?
Well, you name it.
If it’s dangerous, it can threaten the structure.
That can be one of various forms of barbarian,
right?
Any person from another culture, an alien
in science fiction, a terrible monster that
lives in the deep that had been dominated
and oppressed before but has come back for
more, an agent of horror, that’s a common
theme in modern horror movies, right?
An object that moves, the ghosts in the basement
because the dead were improperly buried, etc.,
etc., etc., anything uncanny, anything fear-inspiring,
anything reptilian, anything that smothers
or entrances, or seduces, or you name it;
if it’s change or some metaphoric representation
of anything that can change, then it’s this,
the dragon of chaos, and that’s the thing
that always threatens the stable state in
its multiple potential manifest forms, and
what does that mean?
It means the apocalypse is always happening,
right?
the end of the world is always before us,
which is why you see apocalyptic images, for
example, throughout the new testament Christ
says: “The world is coming to an end”,
and people are waiting around for it to happen,
but what they don’t precisely understand
is that the world is always coming to an end,
always, and that’s because what you think
now is not good enough for the next second,
right, you have to change because change is
coming, and what change means is you have
to let go of what you know; that’s the apocalypse,
and it’s always on us.
The structure is threatened.
Well what do you do about that?
Well, you can run, but you can’t hide, right,
that’s the theory, and the reason for that
is that even if you are unwilling to face
the threat that’s right in front of you,
no matter where you run to that threat’s
going to be there, and so you see in the case
of a aggrophobic woman who starts to run away
from the shopping mall when she has heart
palpitations that then she runs away from
the subway, and then she runs away from taxis,
and then buses, and then other people, and,
and then finally she’s at home and there’s
nowhere to run but her heart’s been palpitating,
and the fear of death is still on her, and
there’s no place to go, so hiding isn’t
much of a help.
or you can pretend that the chaotic thing
isn’t there and refuse to change, but all
that does is make the threat bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger, so just like, simply
put, well say you only have a hundred dollars
in the bank and you have a hundred and ten
dollar telephone bill, and you think, well
I, huh, I’d like that hundred dollars, I’m
not gonna pay that telephone bill; it’s
just a little threat, right, but then you
don’t pay it, and the next month it’s
a hundred and twenty-five dollar telephone
bill, and then they slap a fifty dollar charge
on you, and then they cut off your phone,
so then you don’t have a phone, then you
miss a job appointment, and that’s not so
good, and then it’s two hundred and fifty
dollars to pay your phone bill and another
two hundred to get it hooked back up, and
then your credit record goes all to hell because
you haven’t paid any of that, and then you
can’t buy a house when you’re 25, and
you think, kind of weird, eh, little bitty
chaos turns into a great big monster, and
partly that’s because everything that looks
separate from everything else isn’t, it
just looks that way, and when you ignore anything,
especially if it’s impeding your progress,
you know it’s impeding your progress, you
know you have to deal with it, step away from
it and see what its true nature really is,
so you can hide, and you can not change, or
you can pretend that the threat doesn’t
exist, but in the final analysis that just
stores up the catastrophe for later.